what is the measure of angle e AC so we
have this symbol here which means angle
and then these three letters e AC now to
measure angle EAC we need to first find
angle EAC down here on our picture and
the way we can do that is use these
three letters and we're going to go in
the order that they're given to us so
the first letter we're told is e so the
first letter we'll find down here is e
from there we'll go to the second letter
a and then finally from a we go to our
last letter C again in the order that
they were told to us so this opening
right here is our angle we want to know
how many degrees is this opening the
most common way to measure an angle
would be to use a protractor but we're
not given a protractor so we can't do
that but we do have enough information
on this diagram down here to solve this
what we can see is that our large angle
e AC is made up of two smaller angles
this first one angle e a D right here
angle E a d-plus
from there it picks up with angle D a AC
angle D AC these two angles this first
one from here to here and then the
second from here to here when they're
combined they make the same size opening
as our angle so if we can combine these
two angles we will know the measure of
our angle because again these two
combined are equal to our entire angle
so let's do that starting with E ad we
can see we're told it's 60 degrees
that's a 60 degree opening plus angle
DAC has a 75 degree opening and so if we
can bind
that if we go sixty degrees to here plus
another 75 down to here we've covered
our entire angle our entire opening is
60 plus another 75 so we can add these
to solve for the measure of our angle
six 10s plus seven 10s is 13 tens or 130
13 and then that zero is there because
we're talking about tens plus zero ones
and five ones is five ones
and so 130 plus five is a hundred
thirty-five degrees so the measure of
our entire angle angle e AC is 135
degrees